make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin you know once upon a time
on the weekly pull podcast sal made a
joke and this joke was based on the idea
of the new 52
dc's reboot and he's he's like he's like
the way i bet this went down
it was it was something to this effect
i'm paraphrasing here but this was three
years ago
he was like i bet they were all sitting
in a board room right like they're all
sitting in a room and they were talking
about like flashpoint and everything
that's gonna happen it's like okay so
like here's a story here's what happens
here's what takes place and then at the
end of it barry allen goes back
and he like he lets his mom die and then
everything goes back to normal and
somebody was like but what if it didn't
though
what if the whole timeline reset and
like we basically reboot right like
that's how new 52 came into existence i
feel like that's kind of what's
happening here the thing about scott
snyder and i want to kind of preface
this for a minute the thing about scott
snyder he is a ridiculously amazing
writer
right like there's there's no doubt in
that point scott snyder is nuts at what
he does i almost be scared to see like a
scott snyder marvel story but i feel
like this
this started out as as just kind of a
story that snyder wanted to do and then
it feels like it's turning into a reboot
that's exactly what it feels like it's
turning into dc says it's not what's
happening
but it feels like it is right like it
feels like it's turning into a reboot
right so and you guys will see what i'm
talking about
by the time we get to the end of this
but what we end up doing here is we pick
up initially with kind of the
the the aftermath of the last story that
we did and up to this point we've more
or less kind of had the day saved all
the plot threats have been wrapped up
except for one uh you had the the
speedsters who were basically out
running the batman who laughs in pursuit
of the mobius chair they ultimately
ended up getting it and now they've kind
of gotten back to safety you had the
green lanterns who had kind of gone
into the multiverse along with captain
carrot and and all those different guys
and their
their job was to basically destroy the
antennas that were powering perpetua
which they successfully did
the only real remaining plot thread that
was left here was batman superman and
wonder woman
right and the idea behind them is that
they were gonna go into what was
effectively
these different crisis worlds right they
were going to go into the dark
multiverse and they were going to find
the dark multiverse versions
of the original crisis on infinitiers
infinite crisis and final crisis right
the three major crisis events that dc
has done but
you kind of have that going on and the
idea was that you ended up having like
jaro and you had jonah hex and you had
swamp thing and harley quinn and they
were kind of staying behind his anchors
that when the time came when the
missions of batman superman and wonder
woman were completed that they would
basically yank them back out of the dark
multiverse and into the positive
multiverse and then you know they would
go on and and
basically face off against the batman
who laughs and the whole idea here is
that when they arrived here when batman
superman and wonder woman arrived in
their respective crisis it was not what
they thought it was right batman showed
up here into the original crisis on
infinite earth's event and everything
was just all white and he was just met
with what looked like this little this
little kid who revealed himself to be
the anti-monitor and that's what he says
here
right like like batman's like okay we
have these alfred boxes the whole idea
is to take this crisis energy to
basically absorb the entirety of this
universe more or less into these little
alfred boxes and then take that energy
and then give it to like wally west
right so that wally west can basically
be powered up using his portion of
the power of dr manhattan and then
destroy the batman who laughs and and
the whole point is that once he gets
here he basically realizes it's the
anti-monitor and the anti-monitor
basically says no like this is not the
crisis on infinitives that you remember
that version that crisis that you recall
that crisis was you guys fighting a
whole bunch of uh
fighting me like you you guys the heroes
the villains all fighting me me and the
specter fought each other and then we
basically wiped out the entire
multiverse in the process
i was ultimately defeated and the the a
new universe was born into existence
he's like that's not what happened in
this crisis on infinite earth i won
the anti-matter universe one and i wiped
out all paths of all positive matter
across the multiverse there is nothing
here but me
i am the only thing in this universe
it's all anti-matter in this universe
and it's kind of nuts
somewhere along the line he seems to
have had an encounter with the batman
who laughs who basically seemed to
secure this victory for him right or at
the very least tell him what he needed
to do in order to win and he basically
says like i won against everybody right
like you lost here and so initially you
know the funny thing is batman's like
you have to give this thing back and the
response of
anti-monitor is no that's not gonna
happen now from here you switch over to
the final crisis and it's kind of
interesting the way this is done right
because it kind of blends two concepts
of the final crisis together as most of
you guys know
when it came to the crisis events in dc
comics right crisis on infinitives
destroyed the multiverse infinite crisis
brought it back and final crisis made
the heroes aware of the multiverse's
return right that was the the whole idea
behind this and the nature was that
during the final crisis it was kind of
the quote-unquote death of darkseid to a
degree but darkseid ended up returning
on earth and then trying to secure the
anti-life equation which he successfully
did but while that was going on you also
had another story involving a character
named mandrak who was kind of like this
fallen monitor it was weird grant
morrison was writing like two stories at
the same time in one story and it made
it overly complicated
and exceedingly confusing for a lot of
people but the idea is that darkseid of
course was defeated at the end of that
story and then so was mandrake right
mandrake was defeated but it took the
combined efforts
of pretty much all the remaining
superman from across the multiverse to
defeat mandrake right what happens here
it looks as though mandrak was
successfully defeated but darkseid won
right darkseid basically ended up taking
over the funny thing about this too and
this is what's kind of crazy about this
is that when superman gets here he's
kind of looking at that right he's he's
he's he's talking to darkseid and
darkseid like he's
he's like your energy signature like
you're the real dark side and he's like
yes
i am the real and definitive dark side
now one of the the ideas that you have
out there in dc comics is you have you
have kind of two versions of dark side
so to speak right you have
every version of dark side that you've
seen and then you have true form dark
side now true form dark side we did a
beyond omega level video on
that one was really kind of fan service
the reality is that a true form dark
side is really more of a fan theory it's
not actually set in stone it's just
something that people believe
exists out there largely because of
grant morrison but that's the only real
indication to believe that it's true uh
there's no
there's nothing definitive in dc that
says like you know there's a true form
dark side a true form dark side out
there anywhere but the idea is that if
that theory rings true then you've
basically got dark side as he actually
exists right like the the walking
talking embodiment of pure evil which
can never truly be destroyed and then
you've got like the version that
superman fought during final crisis or
the superman's fought at any point in
time
and that's like an avatar right so
basically it's like a weaker version
like a weaker projection
of darkseid himself but true form
darkside could never actually truly be
destroyed the other thing that that's
interesting about this
is that if this is the true signature of
darkseid then
what it basically looks like is that the
batman who laughs
went and met with darkseid and said hey
like i can take you to a place where you
can win
right like you lost during final crisis
but i can take you to a place where you
can win final prices and he basically
ended up bringing darkseid to the dark
multiverse right it's the only real way
to reconcile this that this is this is
dark side from the positive matter
multiverse in the dark multiverse and he
successfully conquered the world
using the anti-life equation has
dominated the wills of
everybody on earth more so than that
when we talk about mandrak and the
different superman from across the
multiverse you've got different superman
here
right like you've got like red sun
superman and so on and these guys being
here and all basically being servants to
dark side kind of shows that a coming
together of the superman from across
what was left of the multiverse during
final crisis happened and that seemingly
dark side managed to get his hands on
him and basically ended up enslaving
them now it's kind of important to
understand there's a lot that's
not being explained here by scott snyder
right there's a lot that's just not
being done here and this is why i say
i feel like this is kind of a reboot or
it's kind of it's the tail end of it
kind of seems to be rushed pretty fast
because snyder's not really one to kind
of leave you dangling on questions with
a story like this if it was like a great
big huge ongoing event so if we were
talking about like his new 52 batman run
then you would see like the introduction
of a plot thread that would become
important like three or four story arcs
down the road but as far as i'm aware
this is not going to be some great big
huge long lasting event that's going to
span for three years right this is not
hickman's avengers and new avengers this
is just a single self-contained story
and then we move on to the next one and
so it's it's
it's kind of strange here that snyder
would sort of give that to us but the
thing that darkseid basically says is
like all these guys are my servants here
and so what we're gonna do with you
is we're going to put you in the pits of
apocalypse we're going to put you in
this not really the pits of apocalypse
but we're going to put you in the fire
pits and you're going to re-emerge as my
final son right you're the one thing
that's basically standing in my way here
once i have this
then essentially we'll bring an end to
this crisis and we will pass this energy
on to batman who laughs and that'll be
the end of it and then you end up
switching over to the infinite crisis
with superboy prime of all the different
villains who are here
superboy prime is actually the most
rational and i know it doesn't really
make any sense to say that i know it
sounds weird i mean this is a guy who
punched reality
lost his mind and attacked the heroes
but the the important thing to
understand
about superboy prime is he never came
from a place of evil
the the idea behind superboy prime is
that he was basically a character from
before the events of crisis on
infinitives right he was from earth
prime
back before crisis happened but because
of the fact that there was no more
multiverse and because there you know dc
kind of wanted to write his character
out they ended up basically moving him
onto the paradise dimension and up until
the events of infinite crisis the
paradise dimension was
basically more or less like a heaven
kind of place right where he would
basically go on
and find peace now in the events leading
up to infinite crisis which is a
storyline called countdown
you kind of ended up getting this
explanation that the paradise dimension
was supposed to be a place of happiness
but one it was poisoning lois lane who
was originally from earth 2 before the
events of crisis on defenders and super
boy prime was watching all the heroes
right and
from a publishing standpoint when you're
looking at the post-crisis landscape
because of stories like the dark knight
returns by frank miller in batman year
one
you saw stories getting progressively
darker right the heroes becoming edgier
more of anti-heroes than traditional
heroes and so it was
you know jeff johns kind of wrote that
in the sense that he was almost kind of
putting himself in the place of superboy
prime right that jeff johns as a writer
had kind of become dissatisfied
with the darker nature of dc stories and
super boy prime inside this paradise
dimension had looked into the main dc
universe and continually monitored it
and basically said that like there was a
time when heroes fought bad guys right
you knew who the heroes were you knew
who the bad guys were there was no
blurring of lines there but now the
lines are blurred all over the place and
in his dissatisfaction and his
frustration he was manipulated into
shattering this barrier of the paradise
dimension which led to a bunch of
reboots right the return of red hood and
all that kind of stuff but that's what
led to the introduction to superboy
prime but he's not a traditional villain
and that's kind of the important thing
is is wonder woman's chance to kind of
reconcile with him is what's interesting
here because you basically have this the
situation where like you still have the
towers
right the the towers that were used to
recreate the multiverse during the
original infinite crisis event
you have these towers that are here
which he's currently imprisoned in but
superboy prime's like in this world that
i live in right this this universe that
i'm in
i made you guys better you know and then
that's that's kind of a funny thing and
it's a really good way for snyder to
kind of pay homage to superboy prime
because we never actually got a chance
to see
what a universe under super boy prime
would look like right like what would
that earth look like and
we're kind of giving a glimpse here and
we're basically shown that it's a return
to the old school way of doing things
right it's a return to the way dc comics
was in like the 60s 70s and early 80s
right
like they were good guys and they were
bad guys and there were no blurring of
lines here right there were no
anti-heroes there was no good guys who
sometimes do bad things because the ends
justify the means it wasn't like that
right
it was a good guys a moral compass they
always did good things they never broke
from that moral compass and that was the
end of it and so by all standards of
measurement he's
actually made things better and it's
kind of a funny thing because what's
with wonder woman trying to reconcile
with him right wonder woman talking to
him here
one of the things she says is is where
superboy prime says that like you know
in a few minutes
these alfred boxes right the one in the
antelope or the the uh
the anti-monitor universe the crisis on
the fenders universe the one that dark
side has during final crisis and this
one we're going to destroy all these and
all this energy is going to be sent
directly to the batman who laughs
and and the idea was was the reason why
these exist here in the first place
because remember the batman who laughs
created these worlds right so that's why
i say seemingly he went to dark side and
said here's a world where you won final
crisis right he went to anti-monitor
said here's a world where you won the
where you won the original christ on the
finance event and he went to superboy
prime and said here's a world where you
basically won
infinite crisis when those worlds are
destroyed that energy will be sent to
you know the batman who last who will
amplify himself but one other thing that
i want to talk about here
is superboy prime being here in the
first place so the the last time that we
saw superboy prime or at least you know
kind of the time before the last time we
saw his character he was locked in the
source wall and the source wall was
destroyed and the question a lot of fans
had
is where's superboy prime right it's one
of the first things people ask
we didn't really hear hide nor hair of
his character until we got to uh jeff
john's shazam run
but the the whole thing here is that
super boy prime kind of was was defeated
and then quote unquote handed over to
the justice league we don't know how
this reconciles right we're not entirely
sure where these two things stand
i mean the fact that he's here kind of
points to the idea that he was basically
taken by the batman who laughs from the
justice league that seemingly when all
this popped off right the whole dark
knights metal event popped off that what
this meant was a super boy prime was
you know where he was kind of probably
left in some prison cell by himself and
then batman who laughs came took him and
then brought him here right you know
that kind of seems to have been the case
we could just sort of explain it away
until we actually get an explanation
from someone but the funny thing is that
this world he created is a great world
sure it was built on the suffering of
others right it probably required him to
kill some people but he did make a
better world
and notice how wonder woman fights
against him the funny thing about this
is is
often times i think people kind of adopt
this mentality that like i want things
to get better but i don't want to
sacrifice anything in the process and if
you want to make an omelette sometimes
you got to break a few eggs and so
because of that you know it looks as
though super boy prime conquering this
world while it doesn't really look like
the heroes are subservient the reality
is we're not given a lot of context here
right we're not really shown a lot of
context
in terms of what his world looks like
outside of the image that he gives us
right but it looks like it's scott
snyder basically saying like the world
superboy prime made
is actually a better world it is
actually better than it was
before he took power right so it's kind
of interesting right it's kind of an
intriguing
thing but from there we actually kind of
stepped to it to an aside for a second
and we end up picking up with like robin
king and these guys right now robin king
does have his own one shot if you guys
are interested we can cover it but
you know the idea was that robin king
had kind of shown up and lost an attack
against like swamp thing and
and jarrow and harley quinn and jonah
hex and all them and jonah hex ended up
staying behind
and so once that escape was made the
concern was that jaro would be cut off
from like wonder woman and all of them
and wouldn't be able to pull them out of
the
of the crisis world in order to save the
day and so what ended up happening here
is robin king basically kind of pops
back up with the head of jonah hex and
whereas he's kind of beg you know where
harley quinn kind of begs hey like can
you like
like let him go right i mean there's
really nothing left for you to hurt
anymore robin king kind of being as
twisted and screwed up as he is right
this little batman this little bruce
wayne who's just a total dick it's kind
of like no i mean there's there's always
more to hurt but one of the things that
he brings up here
is basically this knife that was forged
by a guy named niron who's considered
the lord of hell and he says if you're
stabbed with it
and you're a sinner then you go straight
you basically go straight to the lowest
pit of hell and he's like that's where
the demons basically take this form of
the people uh that you've hurt over the
course of your life and they peel your
skin off every single day and every
night it grows back
and you basically endure that process
for all eternity and so harley quinn
initially tries to launch an attack
after roman king basically stabs jonah
hex and ends up killing him
sending him to the lowest pit of hell
and then of course you know harley quinn
is stopped by jarrow because it's kind
of like we don't really have time for
this
from there like you know it's it's it's
kind of a psychic attack of sorts is
made where it kind of seems to
you know either crush uh crush you know
robin king uh you know with a whole
bunch of rubble or at the very least
kind of create a
you know create a little barrier there
but it gives them time to run away but
it gives them time to get away and so
kind of jumping back to the the various
other characters here you basically end
up kind of you know traveling back to
the crisis on a finite earth event and
the idea is that the anti-monitor starts
breaking down batman right he basically
starts to dissolve batman
in this crisis universe using
anti-matter to to eliminate his
existence right and then from there he
crushes the alfred box at that point you
switch over to
uh to darkseid who fully submerges
superman inside of the
of the fire pits and superman is kind of
like okay like there's nothing he can do
right like he begs it's almost like the
the beginning of earth 2 from new 52 if
you guys if you guys read that uh and
then of course darkseid ends up crushing
the alfred box as well and then you've
got super boy prime and the idea is that
the antenna is getting ready to fire up
you know and it's getting ready to
divert all this crisis energy directly
to the batman who laughs and then at
least the mobius chair right you know
who that man who laughs will have
but the the whole point here is again to
kind of reiterate the alfred boxes will
basically be used to take all this
this crisis energy and send it into the
mobius chair and so the whole thing here
is that wonder woman kind of begs right
and this is what's interesting is she
kind of makes this case where she's like
you know
the only thing out there the only
constant out there in existence prime is
change things change people are afraid
of change the idea of super boy prime
is such that where he was always
depicted as a character who was kind of
locked in the past but it's kind of
funny because looking at this you know
i'm almost inclined to sort of adopt
this mentality that just because things
change
does not mean they change for the better
and that was the stance of superboy
prime kind of looking at it you know a
little a little more exclusively
that was the stance of his character
just because things have changed
does not mean they're better and wonder
woman begs them please right she's like
i want you to picture the whole
multiverse right picture the entire
multiverse an infinite multiverse right
every single earth is unique but they're
all connected
there's an earth out there somewhere
where you can have the light you can
have
the earth the reality that you want
right where you can have a place where
the heroes are the way that you always
imagine them right like
it has to exist out there somewhere we
suddenly just haven't found it yet and
that's a place that you can call home
but
it's kind of interesting because you
know making this case things change they
do but but
ultimately like wonder woman basically
ends up breaking herself free and then
initially you know tries to go after
super boy prime where at least he throws
her you know into a wall
and the two of them seem to kind of
engage into a little bit of a fight all
the while the antenna is continually
counting down right then it says like
it's ready to fire and that's when you
end up finding out here the antenna is
basically an anchor point that the
energy of the crisis on infinite earth's
reality where anti-monitor is and the
energy of the final crisis reality where
where dark side is those are channeled
in the antenna on the infinite crisis
universe where super boy prime is and
that antenna will in turn
fire that energy into the mobius chair
like a cannon shot
and so what you end up getting here is
is wonder woman who successfully manages
to rationalize with superboy prime that
in his frustration he basically goes to
goes to attack her and says
stop right because and the way she does
this is actually really really cool the
way she does this is a supervised
prime's belief
with the whole idea of the multiverse is
saying the problem with that is we still
have to believe that or we still have to
accept the fact that there will be other
worlds out there that will destroy ours
right like it's a shot in the dark if i
ally with the batman who laughs he will
give me the earth that i want and there
will be nobody out there who can destroy
it right there'll be nobody out there to
destroy the world because there will be
nobody left but she says at the end of
the day though that's really all it is
right like you you idolize superman
right you look to superman as the
greatest hero of all time you idolize
him
isn't that all he really is just a shot
in the dark the hope that things can get
better that's really what superman is
though the idea of superman was to lead
people to a better future not drag them
there
not force them there but to show people
a better way but
this kind of rationale resonates with
superboy prime and what you end up
basically getting is the destruction of
darkseid's reality the destruction of
the the crisis of an interest reality
and this energy
basically being channeled into the
mobius chair by super boy prime right
super boy prime allies himself with
batman superman and wonder woman now
this also kind of begs the
question how is it that superman is kind
of back to normal i guess it's just the
results of the reality being destroyed i
don't really know we're not really
giving an answer here but ultimately uh
you end up having you know jarrow who's
able to reach out kind of bring them
back to the positive manner multiverse
the problem is that when they get back
here
the energy itself was all transferred
into the mobius chair but it didn't work
and the reason why it didn't work is
that the batman who last rigged the
mobius chair so that when the energy was
transferred into the chair it would
automatically be diverted to the batman
who laughs and he basically says all
this energy is now in me
right like i am i have essentially
reached my final form i am empowered by
all the energy of dr manhattan so he
says let me be the first person to
welcome you
to my new age when this when all this
kicked off we had the new 52
now we have the last 52 worlds in
existence but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob cork if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
foreign